feel Vaughn up in the house Gucci gang
sign Gucci carrying even text Gucci
kicking me out here dude it's good to be
a man this is the gayest little
microphone it feels like it's all up in
your grill oh it feels like a WoW like
I'm the weakest one arm blackhead is
trying to give me a hug feels I did like
you're like oh like whoa somebody feed
this boy and then bring him back to the
hug ring you know because he ain't ready
for [ __ ] real too long this dude
ain't ready hug him with one arm he's
not ready would for them was she
annoying first and he started beating
off or was he headed as he beat the
devil I think he had a bit of it and I
do
I could see it in his eyes he was
chopping me just hoping I'd go to sleep
he would drug me but not to have sex
with me he would drug me so that he
could freely masturbate leave his socks
on he wouldn't even take his pants off
they put a hat on he was an animal the
worst is if you're jerking off with a
hat on bro you're going to hell that's
the most French thing you can do straw
Kentucky Derby ass what's worse is you
have to balance yourself [ __ ] chimney
sweep at the best thing one of those
Chinese has broke as if you squat down
low enough to the ground you can almost
hide under it things be dope bro the
most confusing would be like one of them
Daniel Boone raccoons no way [ __ ] out of
my way with his tail oh right about to
finish you distracted by the tail
choking up dusty [ __ ] fur
and it's hard to jacket them you're
breathing out real fast right yeah it's
more of an it it's more of a intake
sport yeah you know so when I'm in LA I
feel relaxed mm-hmm right and if I go to
like wherever you're from I probably go
into coma yeah yeah I'm probably gonna
coma and never wake up again
yeah because it sounds that Calma sounds
boring we didn't have a lot of Asians
man we had a young there was a rumor of
an Asian when I was I'm not sure it was
[Laughter]
and I've talked about this before they
had yeah they had a rumor that there was
an asian kid right and this is after
because we got a Latino kid we got a
Latina not a family just one kid well
congratulations
one guy one guy Nicholas was his name in
a little bit of light facial hair girl
eyes everybody was fired up about that
there was a lot of rumors and stuff
going on
because yeah people had never seen that
on children you know it's like wavy
light hair on the face yeah like this
yeah people are like he's trying to grow
a sideburn on his on his chin yeah so
then I was on the wrestling team in
middle school kind of sweetest anis
Kiedis right there because Penasquitos
was 60% Filipino so anyway so the facial
the rumor of the Asian though you heard
a rumor yeah they had a rumor that there
was an Asian boy in Slidell Louisiana
which was probably about 17 miles away
and so we had to get over there you know
guard up and we thought about it for a
couple of weeks and then we started me
on to my buddies cut grass man this kid
Danny yeah who was a good friend of mine
and he had some he had a couple of
different deficiencies but he's doing
okay now yeah you know and we raised up
some money saved up some money over two
months and then we called a taxi over
there yeah and we went to this place
where they're supposed to have you know
this asian boy Chet I want to say the
name was Chet I'm trying to think off
the text somebody Chang does that sound
to change to change yeah yeah the chat
[ __ ] right sound do you ever see them
doesn't sound it sounds it doesn't sound
plausible it sound plausible because
I've never met an asian guy named Chad
yeah there are in Southeast Asia there
you go either I think it's either tie or
mate bruh check me so we got there and
he wasn't there it was a wasn't there
when he hit the bottom huh
dreams came out of him bro but dreams
doing guts and blood no I just mean you
could just feel the [ __ ] fragments of
ideas and hope and imagination fly out
of his body we're talking about being on
podcast and he said we're talking about
Rogge and I said you were on there for
three hours so he said I never talked
anyone for three hours
yeah man will join I didn't know he we
didn't know each other you know and I
was the first that's the first time
you've had a conversation with him I
think so yeah so I did not brought some
oranges over there and uh because
somebody said he likes you know somebody
said he liked fruits and vegetables so I
brought some I had some what are those
tangerines or tangelos out of sack at
Angelo's at the house and yeah it's
offering some tangelos yeah brought what
I had you know it's a way to look at it
have you have you ever been Amsterdam
yeah I feel like you've given some weird
[ __ ] in the incident we went to a sex
shop took my girlfriend over there and
we went and watched this sex show and it
was the main stars were out I guess it
was like a flu going around and said
they had some real third stringers on
the wheel they had like an waterboy and
his and his female cousin in there you
know I mean this is something your
country probably ate these people Kenya
but here's what I'm saying is that it
was like a lazy susan right and so you
get in these little we get in a little
room that are all around this lazy susan
and your little room has a window that
face what's a lazy susan a lazy susans
like a thing that spins around the
grandmother had like if you open her
drawer okay you know you're in it yeah
so there's windows all around this lazy
susan
yeah there's windows all around this
lazy susan and you go in and you get
your
booth and you can go stand in there and
watch it through your window to see the
lady's disease so you can see a few
other people kind of vaguely who are in
their window you can't see them doing
like jacking off in them you can't see
them but you can guess that they're
probably jacking off okay and then you
can see it a little bit in your head
imagination yeah then what was going on
on the show I was in there oh it's too
[ __ ] I mean it was like the guy could
barely even [ __ ] it was like he had
just won like a [ __ ]
drawing somewhere that he'd never
thought he would win you know but he did
all the entries and it was like it was
[ __ ] somebody like Anthony knew he
wasn't supposed to be [ __ ] you know
it's like the first couple times like
you ever peers here yourself but you
don't put it all the way through the
first time you just kind of keep
checking for where it's okay that
possessed to bro it was like you just
try to figure it out on the fly working
freelance working freelance man and the
girl was not hot Oh a girl was not hot
brown and then here's the crazy thing
denna didn't want to watch him [ __ ] no I
wouldn't do you think you have to stay
in your little cage until the Haley
finishes the rule so no you just have to
stay in there until like it's until like
there's a certain amount of time I think
it's three minutes and you get in there
before your door open oh thank you so
then you're like locked in and watching
these people [ __ ] dude and it's almost
it got harrowing man I was like I was
like cheering at first for kind of for
somebody and then I wasn't and then I
just like it's like when you don't to
watch the game anymore
yeah you're over it again turn the [ __ ]
off was your girl feeling it I think she
was due but she and I had a tough go out
there in Europe my eyes just like
traveling around and I wouldn't have a
lot of money so we're doing it there's a
while ago yeah this probably about nine
years ago oh okay
well we are but no I feel you bro I mean
look I feel you man you know a prime you
know I mean I appreciate your thoughts
on it there most I don't
you know I don't have that my fan I
don't mean I don't ever think about it
that much anymore except for yeah no I
mean I mean I'm it's interesting to talk
about the crazy thing is yeah Thalia I
wish I had a ton of like memories and
stuff I was just so young and I was just
so you were partying too probably I was
partying I'm just like 19 honestly how
much did you get I mean I feel like I
probably you know didn't please a lot of
women you know I mean they had they had
they had posted back then imagine being
19 you're good-looking dude right I'm
like an 8 as long as I brush my teeth
I'm an 8 yeah yeah yeah good look at 19
I look I realize that I look like they
do that always
people always accuse a farting I feel
and he was funny probably you know then
why it's actually funny right you know I
believe it exists they caught a dude
near me one time with a lamb know which
almost sounds beautiful when you just
say it
yeah the lines lay with the Lambs yeah
but I don't think when you say near you
you mean in Hollywood
no no you mean when you're a kid in
Louisiana yeah they got a lot of those
[ __ ] natural born mushroom
oh I never told you the hint of that oh
sorry so no I took that bag of mushrooms
to that party right and a bunch of
people ate a mood never had him before
and then we played a game of
hide-and-go-seek right I was like I'll
count you guys go hide right oh no and I
never went to [ __ ] look for them I
never seen one do this 1 Timothy I've
never seen that dude again
even know how to do anything but just
[ __ ] do you have a memory where you
just bombed you know when you're bombing
you got to dig yourself out have you
ever won where you don't get out yeah I
got to what to my crazy members one time
some dude laughed so hard at the show he
came out of the closet to his buddies
just writing for them swear to god he's
like like jarred some minutes in his
stem you know and his buddies like what
[ __ ] dude it's right up by the front
you made him laugh so hard he just
admitted he's gay one of his buddies
spit milk or spill it on that milk beer
yeah you know oh yeah his buddies are
like what the [ __ ] didn't it was awkward
cuz it seemed kind of real yeah so I
mean I've had people say a lot of stuff
feel like that guy's [ __ ] but this
guy seemed like he might have been on a
cinema sexual and then the other time
that I really bombed was because I'm not
trying to [ __ ] you know bringing
anybody the other side of the sexual
Ledger you know but the other time that
I really had a tough time was at
University of South Florida or Central
Florida one of the other and people
always like which one was and I'm like
well who gives a [ __ ] which one it was
great no matter what obviously I'm not
in a cool city in Florida but they
brought me out and a bomb dude bomb
right in the beginning I'm doing comic
three years and I'm bombed and it was
this thing like battled the bands for
their school they booed me off the stage
I was like 800 people booed me some guy
booed me with an American flag like I
was an American you know and I'm sure
you've probably dealt with some of this
[ __ ] but it's like some guy like waving
an American flag and booing you know
didn't make so yeah I'm just going
backstage which is still America you
[ __ ] the Muppet Betty do you like
away well first I thought you supported
me this is the worst part so I saluted
him right even though I was never in
ROTC right and I hated those [ __ ]
dudes I didn't hate him but it was like
really a bunch of just like [ __ ]
closeted gay dudes at our school that
were running around after school with
wooden guns yeah and you'd see him in
the hallway like like [ __ ] taking
cover behind some lockers with wooden
guns you're like
the [ __ ] just lots of figured life that
you lean and one of them like got in
trouble for sneaking a walkie-talkie you
know TC you know because they're not
supposed to have anything but wooden
guns
the cheerleaders dancer does pervert but
they had on like uniforms you know
misfits yeah so I saluted to do you know
but this so then it may it didn't but he
was like against me
yeah then I was like [ __ ] cuz then I was
like oh yeah we're buddies and he was
[ __ ] against ya know so I to go
backstage what they didn't know was I
was in seeing the evening so I had to
come back out on a stage five more times
between each act and introduce the next
act every time you come home with your
boo are they boo every time until the
fourth time it became so funny that they
were doing it every time that then it
like gave me a chance to like get back
in there great alright cool man like I'd
been pushed so far like and uh and by
the fourth time that became the game a
lot of comedians especially this day and
age won't do colleges anymore yeah I
won't do impass cuz you go to like the
thing and it would be pause they were
one of the first people to say who gives
a [ __ ] about weed anybody used to go to
Amsterdam get high well the problem of
the Amsterdam is there's those trains
there's people on bikes it's like the
worst place to walk around high cuz
there's so many forms of transportation
going on there's [ __ ] people
traveling by crow like I tripped out
there man right there's like boats oh
yeah way too heavy bro it's like people
get on boats and [ __ ] you know I showed
up there one time and they had a um Gay
Pride weekend you know and I didn't know
it and had like a lot of homoerotic like
boat floats going by like just single
men just ten tapes and on boats you know
it's like I didn't know I thought that
was just these people were like hella
Dutch gay people know how to do it oh
yeah they party may no one holding them
back there's no yang or you know yin
whichever one it is they're all yang
yeah it's just people yang in each
other's yang in each other that's
happening in space in space somewhere
this gay people they can get pregnant
they get each other pregnant and they're
gay
because how because they're different
guaranteed oh you think that oh yeah
100%
there's Gay Pride whoa Jamie we just
pulled that's what it was bro and I
thought holy [ __ ] I got 1/10 of 1%
Garrett's from looking at that yeah this
is as aerodynamic as they can get play
no one has a shirt on huh there's a
couple of guys with life preservers
no one has a [ __ ] shirt look how gay
this is this is hilarious they're all
buff and [ __ ] there's one girl with her
hand on her forehead in the front of the
book on what in the [ __ ] I can't get no
dick she's like her friend tells me you
gotta get down here there's a thousand
men with no shirt on and they're all hot
oh my god
I'm there I'm gonna get us a ride on the
boat an hour into the boat she's got her
hand and I had [ __ ] me yeah they're all
gay and that gotta slip this 2 on the
right if you could see that I think so
yeah what if his hips is a little higher
I have that dysplasia and it's popular
in people that have that and also
Australian um you think he's just like
standing on something that could be like
just to stop yeah you can tell it's
moving fine seem like he feels
self-conscious about his legs he has on
peut something hot out there you don't
think so
maybe Riley you can't squat anymore oh
yeah dude I'm in that bad back club man
it's hard what you get that I just had a
just I think God just put like a weak
spine in me and so when I was like 27 I
was paint I was painting a wall and I
leaned for like maybe 40 minutes leaning
out with a paint thing and when I leaned
back in my back wasn't right anymore
uncle and chimes I'm all kinds of [ __ ]
do and I was like dude he's one of us
bro yeah do him and I did some jerk me
off by a dumpster excuse me what we work
together we work together where I had a
jerk
Theo off oh I didn't literally jerk him
off at a dumpster good you do what I do
in the hotel room
but it was Meisner we really I think we
touch but you know what I'm saying yeah
we really did it yeah yes I don't have
any I hardly have any feelings left in
my penis anyway I feel like at this age
oh really
and I'm not trying to be weird because
of a lot of masturbation or you get a
lot of girls I think it's a mix of
everything man you know I've been with
some decent women and some just troubled
women and some undervalued women all
right and you still you still hook up
with the ugly ones or what no these days
I mean you know I try to find uh that
you know a little bit of beauty and
everybody but sometimes you got to
really get in there to see you yeah I
mean like right I know what you're
saying what you're saying is to me this
it's like you're okay you meet a girl
line whatever yeah and their face is
fine legit right and then their body is
legit right then you get them naked and
then some things aren't legit is that
what you're saying yeah the foundation
is weak whatever I always said you can't
build a house on sand everybody be more
relaxed know if one day where nobody
jerked on but if nobody was thinking
about it at all everybody would just
calm down a little because I feel like
it's so prevalent now you can hear
people coming in the distance I feel
like now that's the worst row but that's
a whole fashion jerking off when you
used to let your balls hit your hand
that's a straight up that's a
Confederate soldier jerking off that's
the you know the new thing is just shaft
only nobody's [ __ ] with their balls
anymore
you know do when I was growing up we
couldn't even get point we had to get
this dude Nick on Friday would draw us a
picture some [ __ ] you know the price of
the weekend four dollars to this dude
Nick four dollars for drawings bro you'd
pay eight and he had a nice [ __ ]
thing bro you he'd fold that thing up or
you could feel it heating in your butt
pocket the whole way on the bus
sometimes even good the pictures are
though he was so jerk off this guy's
drawing Oh everybody would he must have
made probably sixty dollars on a Friday
and this was in 1995 you know that was
$60 like 160 today oh yeah think about
that yeah I'm thinking about it yeah
dude and we come back on Monday and
people would have like these [ __ ]
busted ass looking all sketches
rain on them he was like oh this one got
rain on it like bro that rain is your
[ __ ] kids in it you're lying about
that what percentage do you think of the
Internet is dedicated to porn but man I
love what you said about Joey Diaz dude
I found myself watching him the other
night and before I knew it I was out of
my seat like this bro like I was at the
end of like it was the end of [ __ ]
and I've never done that but I've never
done that in my whole life yeah
and I'm like what is going on
something's happening to me when I watch
it you know it's almost messed up it's
almost more in a weird way more romantic
than the way you get killed today
today some you know some Mook just shoot
you on the corner runs off you know
there's nothing there's no backstory
there's no side story there's no you
want your death to be room to be
remembered
I want my death to be something romantic
almost if you die you know I'm saying
like when you rather some be part of
something than just you know somebody
runs up and stabs you in the neck or
something well I mean the who is the guy
who stood in front of the tank that's
really that's pretty good Wow you know
it's crazy as my sister can't even read
but what does it have to do with us
right now hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one